turning to south florida where the city
of miami beach has declared a state of
emergency another yet after another
outbreak of violence there during spring
break midnight curfews have been
extended through at least the weekend to
try and keep people off the streets this
latest incident involved a shooting that
sent visitors while scrambling for their
lives manuel bohorkas is in miami beach
with more on the story
[Applause]
gunfire on a packed south beach streets
and crowds of visitors and spring
breakers running for cover this was just
one of two shootings that happened this
past weekend we've had five people
shot on our streets in the middle of
miami beach there's nothing to discuss
this is a public safety emergency this
video shows officers and golf carts
trapped by a crowd of party goers nine
officers have been injured dan gelber is
the mayor of miami beach
i know it sounds unusual for a mayor of
a destination city to say this but we
don't want spring break
authorities have impounded 100 firearms
over the last month and it's not just in
miami beach there were at least 10 mass
shootings across the u.s this past
weekend alone
so we can't really just
stop people from coming onto the city
but we can implement a curfew which
makes them less likely to want to be
here the emergency declaration sets a
curfew from midnight to 6 a.m every
night through monday and bars some
alcohol sales after 6 p.m
wayne and alicia lanier are visiting
from birmingham alabama as moms and dads
we understand that sometimes you have to
implement functions curfew is the right
thing to do i'm okay with it but there
are critics some in the business
community who stand to lose money and
others who say the city's actions
unfairly target the largely black crowds
how do you respond to critics who say
that this is unfairly targeting young
black visitors well it's targeting young
people
that are here and acting in a way that
they shouldn't so it's obviously
targeting behavior and nothing else
of the injured officers and five
shooting victims none is said to have
life-threatening injuries that curfew
will be lifted on monday but the mayor
said if necessary they will bring it
back gail
all right manny thank you